[Music]
police have been able to catch an
escaped mafia henchman
who's been on the run
for 20 years whoa
and it's all thanks to google maps
what's his name fat sal i [ __ ] hate
that google maps
[ __ ] me
fat tony i don't even know that like the
crimes that aren't solved within like i
don't know six months or a year are
continued like pursued
they just go in the shrug folder all
right yeah this is the shrug folder it's
an emoji
they should be in the forget about it
that's stupid
after 10 years forget about it it goes
in the [ __ ] out of here ken
he was miraculously spotted on google
maps outside a grocery store in spain
okay oh this is a 60 year old dude he
was living a quiet life in the region
and found work as a chef before setting
up his fruit and veggie shop why does
that seem like that [ __ ] analyze this
kind of story plot like
gamino used the fake name and was
largely successful in escaping sight
from italian police up until of course
they discovered the image in the town of
galapagos north of madrid oh that's not
fun if it's not an american italian mob
we're still doing the voice thing yeah
ryan's still going to do the same thing
they still all talk like that they all
still throw this in there
he's not from spain though right no no
no italian so yeah we can from new york
or new jersey yeah just mafia that's how
they sound this mafia henchman who
changed his name to manuel was shown
chatting to someone outside the street
corner store
called
in his garden and the big breakthrough
came when detectives investigated the
nearby restaurant mount his kitchen
incredibly on the eateries facebook page
there was a photo of the fugitive who
was dressed in chef white's and despite
it being 20 years since he was last seen
a dis a distinct scar on his face
reminded the uh remained and the
authorities were able to confirm the
man's identity
scar in her face how how much of a
mobster is this guy this is this is the
photo that showed up on google maps why
does that look like such a [ __ ] mob
hangout too yeah
like they're just sitting there smoking
like they're smoking cigarettes in the
front going forget about it forget about
it
does that mean
yeah does that mean that the detective
was also on the job for 20 years and
that's the one he couldn't solve
maybe like that for the detective on his
deathbed gave it to the next guy was
like please find him
a bunch of manila folders find these
guys
never ever ever
one case
i'd be so bored if that was my job for
just my whole entire career is one
[ __ ] case what did he do what did
this guy do he made italian food i bet
he better half is he making italian food
on the menu was something called sena
siciliana sicilian supper which was
possibly a reference to his past life it
was spaghetti you know yeah
so he was arrested on december 17th
reportedly completed uh and he
reportedly was super baffled after being
caught he literally said how did you
find me yeah uh he reportedly asked
police while adding i haven't even
phoned my family for the last 10 years
so the mobster is going to be sent to an
italian jail to serve a life sentence
and has been convicted on a range of
crimes from murder to drug trafficking
and mafia association did you find one
go dude yeah well just let him go go
who was looking at google maps that tied
the tube because like i mean yeah we
could have seen this guy been like
and then you know what's weird is that
google maps always blurs the face so how
did they know was this dude maybe he
looks like that in real life
it was a facebook picture it was a
facebook picture oh
yeah
so uh you can't really go that far
though if you think about it well to
spain
come on across the board you love paige
yeah i mean
out of the country 20 years you probably
still think you won yeah yeah yeah
that's true that's true little cocky guy
uh it's believed that gamino was on the
italian interior ministries list for the
country's most wanted fugitives as well
as gamino being a part of a mafia family
from agrigento in sicily which was
prominent in the 1990s he was first
arrested in 84 and was investigated by
high-profile anti-mafia prosecutor
prosecutor giovanni falcone and the
prosecutor was assassinated by the gang
in 92.
whoa
giovanni after the day of his car so
imagine that the [ __ ] prosecutor who
arrested him at 84
ended up [ __ ] getting murdered by
them blowing up his car oh
[ __ ]
car bomb [ __ ] he was a movie [ __ ] with
murder in 94 and after going on the run
was captured in barcelona three years
later he then escapes prison in roman 02
and authorities were on the lookout ever
since his recapture wow prison yeah so
that's awesome real gangster dude if you
escape prison go to it
go farther away
go like like north africa like get
africa's well maybe you can't fly yeah
that's true huh right this is like i
can't get a boat
this guy's car you can't get a boat dude
yeah i think i think blowing up a car
and getting a boat are very different
things what's harder
get the boat before you blow the car
you gotta do things in the right order
you wanna survive come on come on come
on
pope dude about it shane ipod shuffle
come on you got an order
forget about it that's some g [ __ ]
though that's pretty that's out of a
movie i bet this guy has some crazy
stories i'm actually this guy is a movie
yeah he is for sure this is going to be
a movie it's called scarface
that does he has a podcast it's called
something entertainment value
entertainment something like that but he
he uh he interviews all these mob dudes
one there's like tons of mob dudes from
hitmen to successful guys like from top
like different levels different
organizations and every single story is
just like can be a movie in itself soft
white underbelly does that too yeah yeah
those are crazy mobsters people who
hacked for like 30 years it's crazy are
they like already incarcerated people
that way you can sit down talk to these
people yeah they've already like done
their time yeah so it's like they can
speak freely some of them are famous
they're uh he interviewed the guy from
casino i think or like the guy that was
um well the the robert de niro
the other guy from casita right
no like so these these stories the the
scorsese stories are based off of true
events right and then the people behind
it like the people behind um
willful wall street like the actual with
wall street the actual like um guys from
goodfellas stuff like that yeah wow
i know man [ __ ] crazy it's crazy
sometimes the real story's worse too
yeah and it's a lot longer yeah
obviously
then three hours max or the movie is
needlessly complex whereas i heard that
the way that they killed jimmy hoffa was
like super straightforward how was that
they were well i was one of those
mobsters being interviewed one of those
podcasts but he was like
they say uh hey we drove him all the way
from like wherever the [ __ ] it was
middle america to
all the way to like boston he's like
there's you know how long you would have
to drive with a dead body in your car if
you got pulled over like you're [ __ ]
like he's like no they just like
probably killed him in that area and
buried him in that area and it's over
like that's it you know uh and i think
they even said he even said that they
they might have he doesn't know exactly
what happened to him but they might have
like just just um cremated him and then
yeah it's a lot simpler than saying he's
in the foundation of this skyscraper
exactly you could dig it up somehow or
you could get to it somehow it's more
romanticized right or they say he's like
in um underneath some stadium or
something but you know they just
cremated them one of my favorite uh mob
movies is casino
by far my favorite and um
when i really like something like i like
to go like behind the scenes and and who
the real people were whatever right so
like in the movie what i never
understood is um the nero's character is
a simp he's an absolute simp he can't
get this girl whatever but like he's a
handsome dude it just doesn't make no
sense right but his character the real
life one ed lefty rosenthal when you see
his pictures it makes sense it's like oh
this guy he looks like a [ __ ] dork
like a straight sip and his wife at the
time was a [ __ ] knockout like
it's like
she's way out of his league yeah so then
the yeah the the girl who plays sharon
stone she is like a model type like she
looks great and then it's like your
stereotypical story of this guy
who maybe uses like um you know status
at the casino and then all this stuff to
get the hot girl but then she doesn't
really like him and i'm like oh this
make they should have casted a little
complex yeah it's hard to to believe it
when you see a character like de niro
right yeah and you know it's de niro so
it's even cooler and james woods in a
body cast somehow scoring with her
though right the whole time
a weak little pimp it's like he's the
one that should be the sip here
you